something to consider about dating apps
is that it's not a 1-1 ratio of men to
women there's about three men for every
one woman imagine everyone on an app at
any given moment just paired off one to
one every man got one woman about 66
percent of men would have no match just
from the ratio alone already the fact
that there's a big big sex disparity
explains a lot of why there's this top
percent of men that get most of the
attention
what's your background
so I have an undergraduate degree in
Psychology I previously was doing a
master's program in research and
behavior and cognition and now I'm in a
second master's program in behavioral
and cognitive Neuroscience so graduate
student should be entering a PhD program
pretty soon not the qualifications of
many of your guests who are the top top
tier of psychologists in the world but
working on it why did you get interested
in attractiveness and dating psychology
so I think probably what first got me
interested in attractiveness and dating
psychology was just how important
relationships have been throughout my
own life throughout the trajectory of my
life I think they're very integral to
the experiences of most people uh kind
of a a core part of of life experiences
that brings value to life and that was
something that was interesting and then
in addition to that uh observing kind of
subcultures online within the manosphere
and that sort of a thing the way that
people perceive attractiveness and
dating a lot of of discourse around that
so understanding those subcultures and
everything also very interesting it's a
fascinating time man to consider the
potential solutions that are being
proposed the challenges that everybody's
facing one of my favorite tweets that
you've put out recently you do these
fantastic tweet Threads Online that
break down go really really deep into
the original data which nobody wants to
look at but apparently you do half of
single men report not approaching women
out of the fear of being seen as creepy
and 82 percent of women reported
experiencing creepy Behavior sometimes
often or constantly and yet I saw in a
different study that around 86 percent
of women say that they want a man to
make the first move
how do you square that Circle
well on a practical level if men are
afraid to approach women find a great
deal of approaches creepy how do you
reconcile that men have to approach and
they're going to be rejected and they're
going to be found creepy at least some
of the time right there's there's no
other way to reconcile that that at some
time it's going to happen something that
surprised me when I posted that thread
and that research uh a surprisingly
large number of people came out and they
said you know you should just never
approach people in public not at the bar
not at the gym not on the street not at
school you should just online date
that's it we have apps for that now a
surprisingly large number of people
basically only thought that apps were
the only appropriate venue now for for
meeting people but certainly that's not
how most people meet right a recent
survey by the Kinsey Institute by match
match hires the Kinsey Institute every
year to do this big poll of singles
nationally representative uh poll of
singles and only about uh 10 to 20 are
actually meeting through online dating
similarly the Pew results from this year
that were just published about a week
ago for 2002 about 10 of all Americans
meet online dating about 20 of people
under 30. so still most people are
meeting in in public a great deal of
those are meeting through friends maybe
about 20 to 30 percent so that's the way
that a lot of people are meeting work
school friends are a big chunk and then
of course online is a big one and social
media is becoming week one as well now
but you know at the end of the day you
have to approach and people will find
you creepy not everyone is going to like
you and what can you do as long as
you're not violating any major social
norms it's okay to be rejected one thing
that William Costello reminded me of
last week was it wasn't that long ago
that people saw online dating as for
kind of weirdos oh my God you've got an
online dating profile what you can't
meet people in the real world how
strange how bizarre is like a sort of a
I know a quirk or some sort of fetish
your perversion
yeah definitely and certainly as a guy
that's getting kind of older now I was
on OkCupid when it was new before Tinder
I was on Plenty of Fish when it was very
very new and no one was on those and
that was the General perception of that
was like oh this is kind of a weird
thing to do and now it's it's become the
norm people almost don't even want to
you certainly there's a cohort anyway of
people that literally do not want to
meet or approach in person probably
going out and approaching strangers at a
bar would be entirely foreign to them
because something I didn't mention okay
so I said about 20 of people below age
30 meet in in apps but about another 20
according to the uh recent Kinsey and
match results uh our meeting through uh
social media so that's another big way
probably that people are meeting is is
through their friends on social media
that sort of thing if it's Instagram or
Twitter or Facebook whatever the case
may be that's interesting so you're
talking you're saying that a whopping
four out of five new relationships
no sorry a whopping two out of five new
relationships are starting
through some sort of online medium
exactly and when I saw the recent Pew
results that were just published a week
ago I thought I thought oh 20 seems low
because I recall results from last
year's that said forty percent meet
online and then just the same day or
maybe a day or two later I saw the
Kinsey statistics and I thought oh well
here's another 20 in addition to that
the report meeting through social media
so if you're asking did you meet online
in past results perhaps you had people
responding that were meeting in apps and
you had people responding that were
meeting Instagram and Twitter and that
sort of a thing and that kind of gives
you that that 40 but certainly online is
is the waste people socialize now
there's a a bunch of contradictory data
that I've seen about people that meet
online having less success in long-term
relationships but also people who meet
online getting married more quickly have
you seen both of these things I have not
I have not but certainly there are
personality differences between people
who use apps at all to begin with and
between people who never do right so
that could be one thing that explains a
lot of relationship outcomes certainly
as far as long-term relationships out go
uh long-term relationships outcomes and
also relationship outcomes as far as age
of marriage if it's an early marriage if
you get divorced those are all things
that have influenced very heavily by
individual differences in personality
and there's a lot of perception that
apps are used just for hookups which
doesn't seem to be the case most people
who use apps about 70 report like
seeking a monogamous relationship but at
the same time there have been studies on
app use that say okay so apps are
associated a little bit with people that
might score higher in dark personality
traits like the dark Triad those are
going to people that have very unstable
relationships as well and also be more
impulsive so that could explain why they
might be getting married more quickly
more impulsivity and also why their
relationships are not lasting as long in
the long term as well uh yeah these
things aren't mutually exclusive they
could both exist together one other
thing that you put to just round out
this uh terrible situation of men not
being able to approach women and yet
women still wanting men to approach them
it's worth adding that approaching women
by itself didn't make the list of things
that women consider to be creepy thus
there seems to be some disconnect
between what women view as creepy and
men's fear of rejection or being creepy
remembering that the very first part was
half of single men I think it was 46
report not approaching women out of the
fear of being seen as creepy and 86 of
women reported experiencing creepy
Behavior but
uh men approaching women wasn't one of
those behaviors that women uh class as
being creepy for the most part and men
see it as the case so this disconnect
between what men view as and what women
actually perceive as and then the final
thing which I thought was such a great a
Great Piece of input and David Buss
talks about this in Men Behaving Badly
which is there is a small cohort of men
that do almost all of the really creepy
Behavior it's serial offenders you know
one man doing a thousand creepy things
not a thousand men doing one creepy
thing each it's not the men who follow
women into the parking lot and refuse to
accept no that are afraid of approaching
women they aren't the ones that are
afraid of of being called creepy so if
you were a man who is reticent about
approaching a woman the fact that you
are reticent already selects you out of
the group of men For Whom the creepy
Behavior would have been accused oh yeah
exactly that's I mean that's a great
Point certainly being approached
politely is not one of the things that
that women typically find creepy I think
a lot of the time with things like Tick
Tock right certainly you've seen these
recent uh videos at the gym of of
someone who looks in the direction of a
woman and then it becomes this big
online thing like oh he was looking at
me creepy I think those can fuel
perceptions for men that even
approaching a woman or interacting with
a woman at all is kind of dangerous kind
of these these you know one out of a
thousand anecdotes that that appear on
the internet and kind of fuel our
popular Perceptions in a way but
certainly asking women is being
approached in and of itself creepy as
you said they would say no and at the
same time exactly as you said the men
who are creepy the ones who really cross
lines are probably the ones that do not
care if they're doing that at all maybe
they don't know maybe they don't care
you know so being just a little bit
conscious of being like pro-social and
not crossing a line it will take you
very far at least if your goal is to not
appear creepy right yes I totally agree
I was thinking about this I actually
went back downstairs from bed last night
because I had something that came to my
mind which was that the metoo movement
sought to sanitize the creepy elements
of men's behavior and instead it
sterilized all of it it just completely
destroyed the desire I often tell the
story about a few years ago I was in
London with a friend who is a big time
YouTuber lots and lots of followers
charismatic outgoing young guy slap bang
in the middle of gen Zed and I was bored
of him and what he was talking about and
I said oh there's a group of girls over
the far side why don't we go and talk to
them and he looked at me like I'd
suggested that we go and kill them
remember them and put them in a park
that he was I've been told that at under
absolutely no circumstances should I
ever ever go up to a girl in a bar that
that's accusatory dangerous behavior
that that's me being a creep
um and yeah I think Joey swole who is
the guy that you might have seen who's
kind of doing God's work at the moment
uh re-centering everyone's expectations
around gym culture and whether you
should approach girls in the gym or not
I'm actually in talks with his manager
about bringing him on the show because I
really want to have a conversation with
him about this but um yeah the reason
that these videos about approaching
girls in the gym are catching fire
online is that they're so obviously
egregious that everybody understands
that this isn't something that's going
wrong that like for a guy there is a
threshold of staring that a guy can
cross absolutely like you know you can
stare too much
but it's not the amount that we're being
shown and the reason that people are
getting righteously angry is because it
hasn't crossed that threshold everybody
understands how to behave in it almost
everybody understands about how to
behave in a normal manner the problem
was me too tried to sanitize and instead
it's sterilized
exactly as you said most people know how
to behave in a normal way certainly if
you look at pro-social behavior and
anti-social Behavior just throughout the
normal day of the person the vast
majority of their behavior will be
pro-social or neutral it won't be
anti-social most people behave normally
in a way that is getting along with
other people kind of not rocking the
boat too much and pro-social not
upsetting other people deliberately or
crossing uh moral bounds or uh that sort
of a thing so certainly another thing
about these videos that we see on Tick
Tock like you mentioned Joe swole great
guy I love these videos but people post
things on Tick Tock like this because it
gets them clicks right it's a whole
genre of controversial things that are
deliberately designed to offend people
to shock people and all of that and you
know they're they're these anecdotes a
lot of them are probably close to
fictional in a way you know did this
woman even actually think that this man
was staring or did she know in a very
deliberate and kind of Machiavellian way
like hey I can make this controversy and
it's just gonna get viral just because I
I can predict that and it's going to get
the clicks and it doesn't matter if the
attention is positive or negative and
certainly you know those into people's
minds and then they form this perception
of negativity the same as you said about
uh the me too movement you know as I
mentioned uh a lot of relationships
begin at work that's been the way that
that it has been certainly work is also
a place where people who are married you
know it leads to Affairs because you're
spending all of the day with one person
and so if work or school or something
like that becomes an environment where
people are afraid to form these kind of
connections and relationships that can
also contribute to you know what's been
called The Mating crisis right or what's
people being single or being lonely like
hey these are the only people I interact
with maybe this person is interested in
me but I'm you know I don't want to lose
my job you know I don't want to get
kicked out of school or whatever the
case may be even if it is appropriate
even if the interaction is pro-social
and healthy and really sure should not
be something that is stigmatized in that
sense
you're familiar with pose law right
which is you can't work out whether a
joke is a joke or not I think we need to
meme into existence an equivalent which
is for click bait on the internet that
you don't know if the girls gym Tick
Tock video is actually her opinion or if
what she's doing is farming for clicks
and because you can't determine which is
which so we need to I'll let the
comments try and come up with some
suggestions for a cool law that kind of
relates to pose law but isn't quite it
uh and yeah dude I mean the the stuff
about
um the workplace I always remember the
story about how Bill and Melinda Gates
met do you know this one I know how so
Melinda Gates was a receptionist working
at Microsoft I think in the 1980s and
Bill had noticed her around the office
thought that she was really hot and
decided that he was going to
call her on the internal company phone
and ask what she was doing so I I it's
Bill I would be interested in taking you
out he says when are you thinking he
said how how about three weeks tomorrow
you said Bill I just don't think that
you're sufficiently spontaneous for me
this isn't going to work puts the phone
down he Rings back 30 minutes later and
says how's this for spontaneous you've
got the rest of the afternoon off so can
you imagine the headline CEO founder of
massive tech company Rings receptionist
to ask her out then after she says no
rings back and forces her to leave the
office to go out on a date with him like
that's game over that is completely game
over and yeah again going from sanitized
to sterilized like is that creepy
Behavior she didn't say no she said when
would you like to go out and how can you
tell the difference between was it uh
flirtation playfulness that she was
doing to kind of do a little bit of a
like a jokey [__] test type thing or was
she genuinely rebuffing him all of these
nuances are exactly why having a hard
and fast rule about you should never
approach somebody in a bar and never
approach somebody at work is going to
end up with people having less sex and
getting into fewer relationships
yeah certainly something like that in
today's environment would be uh heavily
criticized and stigmatized uh and you
know there's arguments against it that
are legitimate and then there's as we've
been discussing like do we really want
to cut off that uh that conduit or that
Avenue to form relationships completely
in the workplace certainly Bill and
Melinda Gates I think at this point they
divorced but they had a
a relationship that lasted for a very
very long time and presumably was a very
very good relationship for that period
you know a relationship doesn't have to
last forever to be functional or good
sometimes relationships end for whatever
reason but
you know in a different environment
would that have even formed at all and
and if that uh way to form relationships
is completely cut off what are the
larger implications for singles in
society as a whole for children in
marriage and that sort of thing you know
certainly population crisis and all of
that what do you think is causing this
rise in sexlessness amongst young men
Okay so
this is something I've certainly talked
about a a great deal uh I think there's
actually a very compelling evidence that
a large amount of the variation in that
is caused by
a decrease in alcohol consumption uh
about 30 percent of the variants from a
recent study that I read could be
attributed to lower alcohol consumption
in the 90s uh certainly I'm old enough
where I was coming of age in that area
people would go to parties very often
they would drink they would have sex
when they were drunk and that sort of a
thing an alcohol contributed a great
great deal to casual sex young people
are using much much less alcohol they're
using drugs at lower rates as well and
in addition to that people are extending
or should say young people are extending
their adolescence
there's many fewer young people uh
between 17 18 19 who have jobs who are
getting driver's licenses who are
entering School particularly men in that
case fewer entering University at that
age and so you have this extended
adolescence you have what has been a
trend I say alcohol but it's actually a
trend as far as lower risk aversion
because sex at that age you know with
strangers casual sex or forming
relationships it's linked to some degree
of risk tolerance it's sort of a risky
behavior and certainly people were
taught that uh in the past when it was
more common like hey don't go out and
have unprotected sex don't have sex with
strangers it's risking behavior and now
the youngest cohort of of adults are
kind of following that advice more and
they're saying hey why is no one
uh having sex why are people not forming
these relationships and all of that
another interesting thing in the peer
results and in the recent Kinsey results
as well about half of people who are
single both men and women report and
this is for individuals under the age of
30 as well report not actually looking
for a partner so again a great deal of
the variance in singleness seems to be
people who have dropped out and is that
because they really don't want to date
or they become frustrated with the
dating Market you know more research
would need to be done to look into that
specifically but for whatever the case
may be a lot of that variance isn't
people that are like out there really
hustling trying to find a boyfriend or a
girlfriend they've given up or or they
don't want to date or something like
that and if there's a generational shift
in people who legitimately do not want
to date the opposite sex or the same sex
whatever the case may be uh that's an
interesting question something that
really needs to be examined a lot I
wonder how much of that is stated in
revealed preferences smashing up against
each other if somebody asks you are you
single yes I am why are you single uh uh
because I want to be that's a much more
acceptable publicly acceptable answer to
give than I'm trying and continue to be
rebuffed or I can't find somebody that's
attracted to me or you know for women
especially I can't find somebody that
I'm attracted to it's a really really
difficult answer to give I would imagine
um but yeah I wonder how much the
um
degrading and the evaporating of hedonic
kind of Larry Behavior has contributed
to this I certainly remember my time at
University which was you know 15 years
ago and we would go out drink heavily
got lots of parties you know that that
was uni uni the the university part of
university got in the way of partying it
was one long party that was interspersed
every so often with exams that I had to
remember the lectures that I didn't
attend to try and continue to State
University but um the Advent smartphones
means that we're all living in basically
a panopticon that at all times any
drunken mistake that you make is
captured and put on the internet and you
could potentially turn into a meme if
you are dating someone but not official
you're going to get rumbled there are
fewer opportunities for people to kind
of make up and break up because you've
got to change your relationship status
or delete their photos from Instagram
MGK and Megan Fox broke up yesterday or
the day before and she went and did all
of her photos with him and you know
everybody's relationships are a lot less
private than they used to be even the
people for whom they want to try and
keep them private
um if the people that aren't you know
movie stars or rock stars so yeah I um I
think that that definitely contributes
an overall trend of risk-taking behavior
being diminished definitely seems like
it makes sense
yes and in a way social media enables a
sort of risk aversion that we have never
seen in the past if you wanted to
interact with people in the past you
know say in the 90s you know you go to a
party where there's other people you're
going to be drinking and maybe at the
end of the night you and someone else
who was drunk you do something and even
if you read it in the morning whatever
but if most of your social interactions
are with people online you can carry out
an entire relationship with someone
online a romantic relationship with
feelings and that sort of thing and
never actually meet them never have sex
and be very very cautious with that
person before you actually decide to
meet in public so there can be a long
lead up to actually meeting which is
certainly and having sex in that case or
forming a relationship or whatever the
case may be that is very very different
from you know I met someone in the bar
and I got drunk and we went home at the
end of the night those are very very
different situations so I think in a
sense social media being able to have uh
social groups online relationships
online most of your interactions and
socialization online also puts kind of a
layer of protection between you and the
world that may not have existed in the
past yes it's like a prophylactic
against any kind of discomfort and the
same thing it goes back up to what we
were saying before men being afraid of
approaching women they already had this
uh dis predisposition toward it in terms
of rejection and now it's been tuned up
even more with not wanting to be
canceled and have their names made on
the internet and then women also are
increasingly concerned
the post metoo era has definitely caused
women to be more Vigilant around men
that misbehave maybe that's meant that
women are a lot more safe but it's also
meant that some women who aren't unsafe
consider themselves to be unsafe they
are looking for problems where they're
not the kind of fire alarm hypothesis of
negativity for uh for how humans have
that negativity bias as well what about
women raising their standards do you
think that they've been doing that over
the last few years
I'm skeptical of that certainly that's a
very very common narrative in the
manosphere particularly in relationship
to online dating the idea that
people on apps have particularly women I
say women on apps have access to this
huge list of men and they can pick from
the best ones at any given moment and
that has raised standards I think that's
probably
not the case uh certainly there was a
large study in about 2018 that looked at
longitudinal data
uh from before and after when Tinder was
released and the rise of online dating
and it looked at Greek students right in
students and fraternities so kind of
like the the students that you would
expect to be the most risk-taking to be
the most popular to have the most sex
The Jock athletic Chads and these guys
only self-reported about you know one
extra partner per year on average
following tender another thing uh
certainly we talk a lot about the
self-reports and stuff with these sexual
behaviors but sexually transmitted
diseases also did not rise in that time
frame whereas on the other hand where we
do see a current rise in STDs is among a
cohort that's actually much younger
about 15 and 16. so I'm not sure that
it's really the case that exposure to uh
more mate options has made women raise
their standards in a sense I think it
might be the case though that that well
I mean it is the case apparently that
many are just refusing to date they're
not enjoying what they see out there and
there's many things that might
contribute to that certainly questions
like obesity could be one you know or
this particularly in the United States
where you you see a lot of people uh
falling into the Obesity epidemic
perhaps
make value overall for men and women
kind of has dropped fewer people are
attracted to one another and that could
explain it as well without actually
having to be kind of a rise in standards
kind of a lowering of standards for
individuals across the board be it men
and women in that case
would you fold into this the female
overachievement in education and
employment obviously you don't need
standards of women to rise if their
level of achievement has gone up it's
not as if you need hypergamy to get any
worse
if women start to sit further and
further up the overall both sexes
dominance or competence hierarchy you
end up with women having the tall girl
problem right that they have fewer and
fewer men that are up and across
exactly and certainly that's something
that has been researched a lot and that
they're looking more into recently right
we're beginning to see more women uh
graduating with under undergraduate
degrees we're seeing women beginning to
earn more than men across many fields in
many areas uh women outnumbering men in
educational roles having higher graduate
degrees as well and if it is the case
that women prefer men who are high in
status right hypergamy the idea is that
they want men that are high in status
but that means high in status relative
to them in some sense
so if women are more educated if they're
making more money it's going to be
difficult to find someone who might be
higher in status relative to them in
that case and this isn't an unreasonable
expectation either this isn't like a
super high standard like hey I have a
master's degree and I have a job I'd
like someone else with a master's degree
and a job well if you get to about age
30 and you look at the married
population you know about 70 percent of
the population is in relationships at
that point and people who have advanced
degrees or I should say anyone that has
a bachelor's degree master's degree and
PhD you're increasingly more likely to
be married both for men and women as
your level of Education goes up so that
pool it gets smaller and certainly
anyone that's not paired up by that
point that actually has a really really
good job or a good decent job and that
has some level of Education their dating
pool for someone is going to be small
especially if they want someone who's a
little bit higher in status than they
are
it's particularly brutal I think for
women because if you've spent most of
your 20s accumulating education and
employment you're now competing not only
with all of the other women who have
done the same thing but you're also
competing with a 20 year old Barista
that at Starbucks that still lives at
home with her parents like the bottom
line is that men don't value education
and employment prospects and their
Partners really at all I think in order
for a woman to achieve the same
uh difference in make value increase
that a man does for a I think it's a
a two-fold increase from a man the woman
would need to have a thousand-fold
increase in her income in order to be
able to make the same uh changing make
value because guys you still matter and
it might actually be a contra indication
you know there's some evidence that
William tweeted the other day that said
um men in relationships with women where
they are not the primary Breadwinner are
statistically more likely to use
erectile dysfunction medication so there
are actually some negative correlations
going on here uh how about being single
for a long time impacting people's
happiness have you had a look at this
I I have had a little bit of look uh of
a look at this so certainly people who
are single happiness is something that's
actually quite resilient there's been a
lot of research on long-term happiness
and the way that it kind of pans out
after adverse life Advance some
classical Research into happiness looked
at people who experienced uh
disabilities following accidents and
also people who went to prison and so
they've
assess these individuals you know
self-reported happiness when they enter
prison following an accident immediately
and of course happiness is very very low
you go back and you talk to these people
later six months a year later and their
happiness is about the same as the
general population so people become very
very resilient as far as happiness is
concerned over a long period of time
whatever the case may be for someone's
life they tend to kind of adjust to it
and it's the new Norm so I'm not sure if
long-term singleness directly impacts
someone's happiness but certainly on an
intuitive level you would think that it
would and if someone wants to be in a
relationship because maybe they come to
acceptance that it's not going to happen
for them and you know they they uh
accept that in their happiness adjust
and they move on but if someone is very
very focused on this on this
relationship goal and they're
continually thwarted that's an ongoing
frustration that can that can stay with
them and certainly even if it didn't
manifest as something that would show up
if you give someone a measure of
happiness it could certainly manage
invest in other areas of their life is
some sort of discontent fewer people in
relationships overall now have you got
any data around that
well overall in the population so I
looked at the General Social Survey
statistics for
2001 so the most recent GSS is for 2001.
and people in relationships even in
younger cohorts have actually been
pretty stable as far as that's concerned
uh typically when you look at the
youngest cohort about 18 to 25
anywhere between 40 to 50 to 60 percent
in the recent Pew data now it says 60 of
men and that was just from a few days
ago and that's actually pretty high if
you look back to about 1984 it was about
46 of men so in the youngest cohort
there's more single young men it has
been going up but since about 2012 it's
been pretty pretty stable about 56 in
2012 if I remember correctly it was 50
something by the time you get to the 30s
though that's an age group that has
remained very very stable most people
form relationships and you have about 70
percent of people who are either married
in a committed relationship and then the
30 who are not so long-term singleness
actually seems to have remained pretty
stable but it has increased for the
youngest cohort it's always been pretty
high for the youngest cohort especially
for young men but it has it has gone out
yeah that increasing variability in uh
male success especially at Young ages is
a reason I think both of us agree that
um some of the black pill and and in
cell culture that young guys are
attracted to
is the sort of thing that they very well
may just grow out of then over time
you're going to end up realizing oh hang
on this was a poor period maybe I was
um late to become socially unawkward
maybe it took a while for me to grow
into my looks or grow into my confidence
or to accumulate a month enough status
or money or whatever but over time you
end up at a place where you probably
couldn't have predicted it when you were
a good bit younger and um it is an
interesting consideration around how
many
of the trends that we see are just
um frictionless Communications of the
internal thoughts that all young people
used to have in the past around women's
fear of safety when they're too young
and vulnerable and they don't actually
know how to
um
put themselves into a situation where
they can always be safe or how to
understand what actual boundaries are
and what might be dangerous Behavior
what might not be or with guys about
just how hopeless they are going to be
in the mating Market or whether or not
this is just a blip up to the age of 21
or something like that
um what about the top 20 of men on
dating apps is it true that all of these
Chads are being showered with attention
and poaching all of the average
attractiveness women
well something to consider about dating
apps first off is that it's not a 1-1
ratio of men to women right there's
about three men for every one woman so
even if imagine everyone on an app at
any given moment just paired off one to
one every man got one woman
about 66 percent of men would have no
match just from the ratio alone so
already the fact that there's a big big
sex disparity explains a lot of why this
there's this top percent of men that get
most of the attention so certainly
that's something that that has been seen
pretty consistently uh another thing is
actually if you look at the ratio of
likes for profiles from this is from the
book cataclysm by Christian Rudder he
looked at this as far as a ratio and
certainly uh women get more likes women
swipes or whatever the case well this
was okay Cupid so I guess it was likes
or even messages in that case and I
think that was from back in the days and
Okay Cupid win you could just send a
message to someone at least that's I
think it was that long ago when when
that data was from certainly I remember
you you would just write someone a
message there was no match or
pre-selection kind of thing so certainly
women get more attention on these apps
there's fewer women minimalist choosy
and men have this strategy where you
know they will just swipe on literally
everyone throw out the big big net and
see what fish are caught in that sense
women are much much more selective there
was a recent study as well that found
kind of a shift in selectivity over time
the more women swipe the more selective
they become as well so the app has an
acute effect in that sense on making
women more selective so there is kind of
this
select a group of individuals on apps
that it works for at the same time
outside of that data other papers and
studies on Tinder show that about half
including the Pew uh recent data that
was just released just a few days ago
they had an online dating uh survey as
well about half of people on these apps
report being happy with them about half
of people report having gotten a date
from them so it's not the case that it's
only 20 of people who ever get any
action from an app so to speak I think
another thing that people kind of
misconstrue about that is they see this
ratio of attention and they think oh
these people are monopolizing all the
women they're they're having all the sex
with all those women but certainly swipe
data or who goes on dates or who gets
messages is not the same as like oh
these people are actually meeting up and
having sex or even going on dates for
that matter so what was that
what's that term that you talk is it the
the social socially select sexual few or
something that there's basically the
people that the most sociosexual just
keep having sex with each other what's
that exactly so this was a term that I
first found I think in when I began
researching sexually transmitted
diseases they refer to the promiscuous
10 percent and certainly these are
people that score very very high in
sociosexuality sociosexuality is a
measure that indicates basically
people's willingness to have sex with
not well strangers have more casual sex
they're less sexually restricted more
willing to have sex in that sense so
this promiscuous 10 percent in research
on sexually transmitted diseases
described okay we have this 10 of people
who report having way more sex this is
both men and women
when they get tested for diseases they
report their sexual behavior and they
constitute a much larger percent of the
population that's responsible for you
know uh the spread of these diseases so
to sit so to speak and these are people
largely having sex with one another so
rather than
the idea that there is 20 of men who are
having sex with all of the women because
this is something that has never been
shown in any of the data and that's
something that you would see in sexually
transmitted disease statistics people
talk a lot about
self reports if you look because
certainly what the self-reports show
they show that about almost 50 percent
of men and women in 2021 per the General
Social Survey data report no sexual
partners another 20 30 or so report one
about 85 to 95 report having sex only in
a monogamous relationship so as far as
self-report data goes across any data
set that you use people report
overwhelmingly being not especially
promiscuous and then you have that
promiscuous 10 percent who makes up like
oh yeah between five and more people in
a year one partner per month new or
something like that and this is the same
population the same cohort that is
responsible for or actually responsible
for but that when they go in to get
tested they constitute many positive
tests for sexually transmitted diseases
as well this is your way of splitting
apart the revealed and stated
preferences thing right okay so yes I
understand I understand what attractive
women are they the ones that are having
a lot of sex or attractive women extra
promiscuous with this dearth of
globalized sexual Marketplace and shakes
on Instagram being able to message them
to come out to Dubai
well certainly the research seems to
indicate the opposite with the most
attractive women actually indicating
fewer partners and women who are neither
the least attractive nor the most
attractive reporting more sexual
partners and that's something that is
kind of in line with evolutionary
theories for why that might be right
because if you're a very very attractive
woman first I guess some background here
would be that women there's a huge
difference one of the most
well-replicated differences between men
and women given from evolutionary
psychology as far as you know
replication replication crisis and
psychology something that's very very
well replicated is very large
differences in sociosexuality between
men and women men are very very open to
having a lot of sex many partners being
promiscuous women much much much less so
so given that basis
a very attractive woman physically has
many many more options she can be more
selective a woman who is slightly less
attractive say medium attractiveness or
something she may actually need to use
sex more to secure mates to secure a
partner or something like that and in
that sense sex serves as sort of a
function to secure a mate in that sense
and then people who are very very low at
the end of attractiveness they may have
difficulty finding a mate at all in that
case so that's probably how you get that
middle range of female attractiveness
that's associated with
uh more sexual partners men on the other
hand the most attractive men
attractiveness is linear as far as
predicting sexual partners for men but
it's also not a very very strong
correlation either what does incentivize
uh female short-term mating then
so certainly uh the Paradigm for
short-term mating
uh would be the Dual mate hypothesis in
evolutionary psychology for a long time
this is what it has been until
relatively recently right and the idea
here was that men and women but we'll
talk about women specifically in this
case uh have a dual strategy for
selecting a mate one strategy is looking
for a long-term mate who can provide
resources form a pair bond and raise a
child basically and the other is a
short-term strategy and that short-term
strategy was very closely related to the
ovulatory shift hypothesis right because
the idea is that
uh when a woman is fertile she looks for
a man with good genes you know and gets
pregnant by this man so that she can
have the good genes and then at the same
time have this long-term mate at the
same time so this was an idea that
persisted for maybe a decade and a half
in evolutionary psychology and at this
point now evolutionary psychology has
shifted very very much away from that
they said you know there actually isn't
that much evidence for this dual mate
hypothesis something uh David bust and
Schmidt recently wrote in an article on
sexual strategies Theory which is what
I've just described it's called sexual
strategies Theory
was that really this short-term mating
strategy probably only applies to a very
very select few women and those are
going to be women who score very very
high in sociosexuality if you look at as
I mentioned uh sociosexuality big sex
differences if you were to look at the
two distributions they're about uh one
and a half standard deviations away from
one another if I remember it correctly
so a lot of men and women don't even
overlap at all as far as these
sociosexuality scores
so what would drive short-term mating in
that case well one of the big motives
mentioned in the recent article by bus
and Schmidt would be money and certainly
that's not what a lot of people I think
think about when they have this
short-term mating discourse they think
oh they they want a Chad who's hot and
everything and all of that but if money
is a big one you know and you can see
this in things like sex work you can see
this in things like the kind of uh
who is this recently Leonardo DiCaprio
he finds very very young women now he
was an attractive man before but he's
getting very very old do we believe that
these women are interested in Leonardo
DiCaprio because he is an attractive man
or because he has many many resources so
these are things that would incentivize
short-term mate strategies but more
interesting than that perhaps is that
the shift has gone from saying ah people
have this all women have this dualistic
mating strategy short-term and long term
saying okay there's actually a lot of
overlap between short and long-term made
strategies that short-term strategies
may actually be kind of a springboard or
a doorway in to long-term made
strategies
a good example of this reported by David
Buss in his research was that about 70
something percent of women who have
affairs they report for example being in
love with their Affair partner and this
has led to kind of this new paradigm in
evolutionary psychology that's called
the mate switching hypothesis which is
that short-term mating is not something
apart from long-term mating it's not
going out there to secure the good genes
it's looking for a new long-term mate so
this short-term mate this playing the
field outside might be like okay maybe
my satisfaction with this mate has
decreased but I don't want to break up
yet I need some kind of security going
into a new relationship so I'm kind of
exploring these short-term things to see
if they become something larger or
something longer in that sense yeah
women monkey branching from one
relationship to another I I found it so
interesting the because the the Dual
mating hypothesis was founded by bus as
well right
yeah so David David both comes up with
this Theory then he kind of reassesses
the data recants his original
um Theory and the problem is it's kind
of like the the same thing when you have
a a newspaper article that accuses
someone of someone uh something and then
publishes a retraction a little bit
further down the line the issue that
you've got is the retraction never gets
as much uh
exposure as the original accusation does
and now we are stuck in this sort of
liminal space where the guys that did
the study say that the study no longer
holds water and this original theory is
still continuing to kind of plow ahead
uh I I don't know
I I I I can't really work out why it's
the case that the Dual mating hypothesis
seems to keep moving when the guys that
says it hasn't replicated either right
when they tried to do this again
certainly so something yeah that David
West said in this recent paper is it's
titled sexual strategies Theory 2021. it
might be a book chapter in the New
Oxford Handbook of evolutionary
psychology or it might just be a review
but you know he he says okay so these
aren't entirely contradictory you can
have short and long-term strategies but
this makes switching seems to be much
more common in this you know actual
women pursuing short-term strategies
pretty rare so that's something to
consider what hasn't replicated well so
one of the things uh that this was very
very heavily based on initially was it
was called you know the Dual mate
hypothesis but a longer title for this
or a version of this would be the Dual
mate hypothesis of ovulatory shifts and
the idea is that when women ovulate when
women are fertile that's when they're
especially attractive to men with good
genes right and that's when they're more
likely to cheat and all of that so
that's what specifically hasn't
replicated very well what we see instead
is actually that women are pretty much
attracted to the exact same type of men
for long term and for short-term
relationships the reassessment that bus
and Schmidt kind of made in this paper
was like okay so good genes are not just
physical either good genes include
things like intelligence they include
things like pro-social Behavior they
include the behaviors that would make
someone stay with a partner and raise a
child and provide resources and all of
that so why would none of those things
be selected for in a short term May why
would it just be physical that's one
issue with that we don't see the shift
in actual preferences that's the big
thing that has not replicated that I
think undermined this a lot and kind of
caused that shift away from it was we
don't see that women seek men who are
more physically attractive when they're
ovulating they want physically
attractive men all the time and so
that's something you know if you talk
about the black pill they don't they're
not wrong about that people like
physically attractive people they like
facially Attractive people a muscular
men and that sort of thing that's a real
thing so and that's something that
persists for both long-term and
short-term so we don't see that there
another one that kind of hasn't
replicated well that would have lended
support to that as well was the good
genes uh immutable competence
testosterone hypothesis and the idea is
okay so when women are ovulating they're
attracted to men who have very high
testosterone high testosterone signals
good genes why is that because high
testosterone causes a handicap in
immunocompetence to have high
testosterone you're actually lowering
your immune system a little bit and that
means that you have to be especially fit
to have high testosterone so none of
that has really replicated very well so
many of these things that we think of as
signaling good genes from an
evolutionary standpoint perhaps they
don't we don't see the switch in mate
preferences for short-term and long term
as previously believed and we see in
actual Behavior as well as reports that
a lot of these short-term relationships
are kind of as you said they look more
like monkey branching than they do a
different strategy they look like
someone that wants to leave a
particularly I should say someone say a
woman that wants to leave a relationship
and enter a new long-term relationship
those huge differences is in
sociosexuality huge sex differences and
preferences for monogamous relationships
as well all of that kind of leads toward
okay women probably are not engaging in
a lot of short-term mating and in a way
it's almost like when people talk about
women that way it's almost like they
ascribe more male personality
characteristics to women it's almost
like if I were a woman that's what I
would do but that's just you know women
are very different in a lot of these
ways Eve mentioned the black pills
relationship with attractiveness there
do you think that in seldom is all about
looks
well I think the the most interesting
thing that's going to happen I think in
research on incels is when someone does
a paper where they actually get a good
sample of in-cell photos and get some
attractiveness ratings and then we can
know to what extent uh looks are
involved I don't think looks are
completely irrelevant you know there's a
lot of people like looks don't matter uh
they just have bad personalities and and
all of that you can find some famous
ones you know Elliot Roger or something
like that this was a man who facially
who you know he could have had a
girlfriend he you know he wasn't uh ugly
in that sense but there's an
intersection there where if people are
not especially handsome and they have
some personality issues and when I say
personality issues I'm not saying bad
people but if they suffer from anxiety
which Recent research on in cells has
shown if they suffer from depression uh
many uh self-report autism they have
official diagnosis of autism about twice
the rate according to recent research by
Brandon Sparks as well you know William
Castillo he found that they suffer from
depression and anxiety and that sort of
thing those are things that can impact
your relationship a lot and if you have
some of those things going on and you're
not the most handsome guy then you have
this intersection that's going to make
forming a relationship really really
difficult what do you think guys get
wrong about what women find attractive
foreign
study survey on on the web about the
Giga chat I took just one photo at most
people I think will know the gigachad
this meme
I think he's a very handsome guy but
importantly he's an extremely dimorphic
guy right his face is extremely
masculine big chin big uh brow Ridge and
everything so it's he has an extremely
dimorphic face and he's also considered
to be very handsome at least in these
kind of meme subcultures of the black
pill that's why he's called the Giga
chat because he is kind of the archetype
of the most attractive man so I ran this
across a large sample of men and women
men overwhelmingly related or rated him
as attractive women didn't
but at the same time there was kind of
uh you know it wasn't a distribution
where most women uh well I should have
said that differently most women found
him unattractive but there were some
women who found him pretty attractive at
the same time most men thought he was
attractive so a lot of the time men kind
of get wrong what women like as far as
the physical features of men I wrote
another long article reviewing uh the
research in that on facial
attractiveness and specifically facial
dimorphism masculine facial features I
think men think that very very masculine
facial features are attractive to women
uh usually it isn't the very most
dimorphic basis
that are the most attractive to women if
you think about a really dimorphic face
it's kind of like a gorilla in a sense
uh but it's probably not going to be the
least dimorphic face the least feminine
there's a lot of research on how
averaging this is attractive and
sometimes when I say that people think
what do you mean how can an average face
certainly average is not attractive but
average in this case means features that
are not too extreme that are symmetrical
that are not too extreme so those are
some things that predict uh facial
attractiveness in in any sense for
personality and what I think men often
get wrong at least in kind of these
manosphere subcultures they tend to
think that women enjoy uh anti-social
Behavior
they tend to think that women are very
very attracted to certain anti-social
traits which is typically not the norm
so if you look at something like the
dark Triad for example there is a
research that indicates that the dark
Triad is attracted to women so the dark
Triad is this uh Triad of traits that
are anti-social psychopathy
machiavellianism and narcissism
so looking at those individually
uh some of those actually predict
attractiveness better than others
primarily narcissism and that might be
because people who are narcissists pay
more attention to their own appearance
and because their behavior is very
different it seems like machiavellianism
doesn't actually predict this kind of
attractiveness not attractiveness as far
as physical ratings nor mating success
as well as the other two do so those are
certain things to consider yeah it is
interesting about how the common held
wisdom on the internet about what it is
that women want I had a Seth Stevens
dividowitz on the show who wrote
everybody lies and don't trust your gut
I mean don't trust your gut he did a
autistic data scientists approach to
optimizing his personal appearance and
he split tested there's websites where
you can do this now but he actually
backended this back in the day
um
he grew a beard put a photo of him with
a beard up should I get a beard should I
have glasses should I have my hair short
should I have my hair long should I wear
this should I wear that and he basically
split tested all of the different
iterations of his appearance down to I
should have a beard wear glasses blah
blah this particular like collection of
things uh and he is now by his own
admission in a relationship with a girl
that he's punching out of his league
with and the reason that that happened
he said and he has data to back this up
which is that you want to try and make
people love or hate the um sort of look
that you have going forward you don't
want to be everybody's just okay you
want to be some some people absolutely
go for you and this the same thing goes
for personality as well that he said his
girlfriend uh maybe even now fiance when
they've before they even got together
was with her friends and talking about
being single and they said so what are
you into what are you into what are you
into and they turn to his future
girlfriend so what are you into and she
says I just love nerds I can't say what
it is about it I've just I have so such
a soft spot for nerds and that is the
kind of guy that I find the most sexy
and sure enough down the line comes Seth
Stevens dividowitz ex-data scientist at
Google and like literally the guy that's
just done a a spreadsheet to work out
how he should look most attractive but
there you go there's you there's your
your nerdy guy
um now certain corners of the internet
would say oh well you know that's just
her beta books on the way to an alpha
[__] solution or whatever it is
I don't know it it seems to be unlikely
to me because a lot of the time I've
seen guys get into relationships with
girls who really love funny men or
really love artsy men or really love
athletic men or really love whatever
it's not all pointing in this sort of
uni-dimensional one-directional way of
up and across towards hyper masculinity
the higher testosterone you're always
going to win like there's certain
Universal symmetrical face for instance
I've never heard anybody say you know
what it is I just love an unsymmetrical
face that's not something typically that
I've heard but there are far fewer
universalities than I think people would
find and when it comes to guys and
advice for guys in dating I think
becoming uh sticking to some of the
absolute un uh deniable rules and then
going okay what am I what am I really
really good at if you're really really
good at being the The Artsy guy with a
hanging earring that can play the guitar
like yo lean into being Mr guitar player
thing or if you're the super funny guy
you know Pete Davidson's the route to go
whatever it might be you can become more
of what you you are and that to me seems
like
not only the
smartest route to go down in terms of
being effective with women but it's also
the root down which you're going to feel
like less of a fraud and this was
something else that you've brought up
with which is this sort of um pickup
artist to in-cell pipeline that you had
tracked through some data I think one of
the reasons that a lot of guys became
disenchanted with the pickup artist
Community was that what they realized
even the ones that were successful if
you were successful at pickup what it
taught you was that the role that you
played was all that women were attracted
to and the further that the role that
you played was from the person that you
genuinely are you realized oh my God I
am so inherently unlovable and deficient
in myself however women of this game to
be played they're this adversary to be
one that is competitor that I'm supposed
to gain control over and if I play the
game right and use the correct series of
neuro-linguistic programming languages I
will be able to
win this game and for the people who did
try pick up and it didn't work either
because they weren't able to do it
correctly or because there was something
about them that meant that they couldn't
get it to work in no matter what they
did
um it was also disin chanting to them
too so pickup to me seemed like a
unfalsifiably
disheartening approach to dating
certainly certainly so what you
mentioned about attractiveness let me
comment on that and then go to the the
pickup because there's two interesting
interesting topics so
a lot of research on facial
attractiveness up to this point has
looked at how much people agree on
attractive faces and when you look at
integrator correlations across a whole
group on attractiveness they seem really
really high you can get correlations
between like 0.6 and 0.9 for facial
attractiveness ratings which makes it
seem like oh man people really agree on
what an attractive face is and it's true
if you look at that metric if you look
within that metric if you run an ICC
correlation and you look at pair ratings
the correlation is much much lower it
can be about 0.2 to 0.3 or so you're
gonna have to explain what you're
talking about here certainly so if you
take a big big group of people and you
have them ready to face and you look at
their ratings
then you'll get a correlation that seems
very very high like most people agree on
what an attractive face is
if you take two individual people out of
that group at random and you look at
their correlation and then you take two
more out of that group at random and you
look at their correlation and then you
compute that you'll say wow people don't
really agree at all there's actually a
lot of variation on an attractive face
there's a good paper I think it's from
2016 maybe it's a little older by a
researcher named honeycomb and he plots
it out on a plot and he says okay so
here are all the actual faces and here's
the highest rating and the lowest rating
and almost every face regardless of how
attractive it was got a really high
rating and a really low rating I
recently ran a survey I have it up on
the website now I took faces from the
Chicago face database
and I selected these spaces male and
female faces to be uh kind of below
attractiveness and about all of these
faces got about 25 of people that said
okay that face is good enough I would
date it even though they were all kind
of unattractive faces as far as
pre-ratings went the pre-ratings highly
correlated uh the ratings that people
gave the participants highly correlated
within each other and to these
pre-ratings so people all kind of agreed
on the attractiveness of these spaces
even across different questions that I
asked like how attractive are these
relative to the population how
attractive do you find them at the same
time if you go through all of these
spaces every single one of these spaces
had people that's rated it like you know
a likert scale one through seven seven
most attractive every single face had at
least someone who said it was a seven a
six a five so there is a great deal of
individual variation and attractive face
even if most people agree that a face is
unattractive they're still going to be a
pretty large cohort that says you know I
actually kind of like that face so that
would be maybe Seth the unconventional
or dude that manages to bag a hottie
because he's exactly what she's looking
for okay and then what about
pick up to incel great so there was a
cool paper from a few years back called
uh I don't I don't think the title was
the answer P waiter in cell pipeline but
that's basically what it described it
might have been called mapping the
manosphere or something like that so
this used network analysis and it looked
at something like 52 forums that were
red pill forums mgtow forums manosphere
forums Pua on Reddit and then it looked
at some of the big big uh forums online
outside of Reddit as well and it used
content analysis to kind of identify
users or identify the kind of discourse
and content and track how those moved
over time and as far as active users and
active discussions and stuff so a lot of
the Pua and red pill forms
they declined and then in cell forums
boom they appear on on the timeline and
already they're beating everyone else
and they're looking at users that
basically migrated from one to another
and you see a lot of cross-migration in
the discourse from those early Pua forms
to the later in cell forums and so the
idea from that is kind of like okay a
lot of people began in Pua communities
and they moved into these in-cell
communities similarly a lot of people
that began in these red pill communities
they now have a lot of overlap with the
mgtow communities which mgtow is of
course men going their own way men who
do not want to date
kind of similar to incels kind of not so
you see these communities that began
kind of like a self-improvement and
gaining advice for men like hey you want
to be with women and you want to date
and we're going to give you like the
tools for that and maybe they didn't
work you know because now all of the men
have gone to these communities that said
no we're going our own way now we don't
want to date or oh we're just in sales
now either way
why do you think that this is the
trajectory that seems to be happening
so I think something that you said was
that even if Pua is successful it can be
kind of dispiriting to people so say you
start Pua and you actually kind of have
a little bit of success with it there's
I think there's a question to be made
it's like is this helping people form
lasting romantic relationships or are
these just kind of moving people into
that promiscuous ten percent because
this cohort this promiscuous 10 so to
speak this is associated with a lot of
uh personality issues people that are
very very promiscuous risk-taking It's
associated with things like higher
scores and dark Triad personality and
all of that and these are individuals
that because they are so promiscuous or
not because kind of as a correlate to
that they might not be forming long-term
relationships they might have a hard
time forming those connections if your
sexual partners are very promiscuous
probably you know that's associated with
more infidelity so something I noticed
observing red pill forms and P waveforms
A lot of these people were like oh you
know someone cheated on me someone
cheated on me all of my girlfriend and
cheated on me and at that point I have
to kind of Wonder like why what kind of
people are you selecting where like all
of your girlfriends have cheated on you
and then they end up you know the men
that started early in that and ended up
later with these very cynical and jaded
views and it's like okay but your own
experience is selecting people might
have kind of shaped that trajectory for
you in a sense and then at the same time
there are many men who probably entered
those communities Pua or something and
got no results at all and I think those
are a lot of the people that have gone
to uh blackfield communities in fact I
think even one of the early in-cell
forums was actually called Pua hate
right yes yes yes and and I only
reminded remember that because I was
listening to your show with uh with Nama
Kates today yeah so certainly these were
people that had experiences of Pua stuff
and they thought oh this is you know not
going to work for me it didn't work for
me it's a grift I paid the money and
maybe I didn't get the results that I
wanted and boom they're going you can
see how that would be a black pill right
you're telling me that the guy with the
big furry hat and the massive sideburns
mystery out of Neil Strauss is the game
even he could get laid with his stupid
hair and his flares and oh and now the
real social dynamics Tyler and Max and
everybody else they've come along and
they're not not all of them were exactly
you know the Pinnacles of Giga Chad
masculinity and it worked for them and
it hasn't worked for me therefore I
should find distaste with this yeah I am
I can completely see why that would
cause people to Cascade down from Hope
to increasing gradations of hopelessness
absolutely and and I think there's a
personality trait that is closely
associated with that which is resilience
so some people they can get rejected a
thousand times and it just brushes off
of them you know like like water off of
a duck's back then get rejected over and
over and over they have very very high
resilience and it doesn't affect them if
they get cheated on they just move on to
a new relationship if they experience a
divorce they get married again these are
people that from their past experiences
they don't let it uh sit upon them in a
sense and other people uh you know their
girlfriend cheats on them they're
they're in love when they're 18 and they
break up with their first girlfriend and
it just devastates them and they never
get over it again so kind of very low
resilience in that sense and I think if
someone is going from a position of very
low resilience say they go into Pua and
they're like okay I want you to approach
a thousand women they go to the
supermarket or the mall and they
approach 100 women or whatever and they
get rejected a hundred times uh that's
going to shape the perception of someone
with very low resilient it's very
differently from someone who who doesn't
care remember what we were talking about
earlier on which is that most people are
a
non-insignificant cohort of people are
not seeking relationships at the moment
more people seem to be risk-averse more
people are spending more time online
than ever before when you combine all of
this together what you end up with are
people who are less resilient having to
them traumatic experiences that can
sometimes be pre-selected due to their
them being the common denominator
between all of the abusive manipulative
cheating girlfriends or boyfriends or
whatever it is that they do then the
large cohort of people online who aren't
disproving any of these theories in the
real world see stories on Reddit that
quite rightly Garner tons and tons of
upvotes because they're shocking this
here's the guy who left for milk and
came back and his wife was having sex
with the neighbor and the dog at the
same time and she left him and took all
of his money and now he's got Crohn's
disease and you know he's living on the
street and he's gluten intolerance and a
club foot like all of these things have
happened to this one guy oh my God this
is why all women are [__] right like
all women are like that
one of the problems or one of the things
that I see online especially when it
comes to trying to encourage guys to get
into a long-term committed relationship
especially one that encourages marriage
is that they would say why would I get
into a relationship like a woman's just
going to take all of my money and do
this thing in any case okay did that
happen to you
or did you read one story or a small
number of stories online that told you
that this is something that's super
super common because dude even the heads
of the red pill movement like even the
most red pilly of red pill guys get into
[__] long-term marriage relationships
like Neil Strauss the guy that wrote the
game
is now this completely renewed Tucker
Max the guy that invented the entire
genre of fratia lives 30 miles away from
me at a ranch in [__] Dripping
Springs surrounded by he's made a
Waldorf School for his kids and him and
his wife have got four and he spends his
days practicing shooting guns and
corralling and stuff oh yeah that's
that's really the the future that he had
planned for himself at the age 25 wasn't
it no of course not like obviously not
even the people that were previously
supposed to be the figureheads of these
entire movements have transcended and
included their experience to now become
family men and yet there is still a very
very common
distaste reticence bitterness uh
toxicity toward that long-term dating
thing again this is obviously not for
either of us to say that some guys
haven't got themselves into
relationships with women who have
destroyed their lives who were the
Machiavellian manipulative that he was
perfectly fine and she took him for all
that he was worth like yep yep that
happens and to those guys I have the
absolute utmost sympathy
um but the fact that those stories are
so egregious online and Garner so much
like
attention is for precisely the reason
that they feel so outrageous that they
are less
representative of most normal
relationships and yeah I I don't really
know what the solution is for this
because for as long as people will take
their cues about what the mating Market
is like from the internet and don't
disprove it in the real world due to
their concern and lack of resilience or
just general fear for any one of the
Myriad of reasons that we've said both
men and women women are going to believe
that every man out there is a potential
rapist and men out there are going to
believe that every woman is a spinster
that wants to take him for 50 of his
wealth
exactly yeah and something you mentioned
that's very important many of these are
very very young men you said have you
experienced a divorce these are some of
these men are 18 19 20 years old you
know have they even experienced a
breakup at that point they do not need
to be worrying about someone taking
their house if they don't even have a
job and they don't have a house and
they're living in the basement and that
sort of a thing baby steps first
worrying about forming a relationship
becoming resilient to deal with breakups
because most relationships will end you
know everyone who gets into relationship
experiences a bunch of breakups you know
that's something that happens to
everyone and worry about the divorce
down the line so you have you know men
going their way mgto if you are like 45
years old and you've been through two
divorces and you're mgtow I totally
understand that like maybe you you are
done with dating and that's kind of
reasonable if you're 18 years old and
you've only had one girlfriend and never
had a girlfriend how have you sworn off
women already that's not reasonable
how much do you think guys actually want
to cheat or sleep around outside of a
relationship if they were able to do it
safely
I suspect it's actually pretty high uh
part of the reason I say that is because
infidelity actually seems pretty high
something about uh perhaps half of main
report cheating in the past if that's
something that they would continue to do
ongoing deliberately to seek it out is
kind of another question they may be
kind of if someone is put in that
situation and the Temptation is there
and they think they're not going to get
caught probably it's actually pretty
high that certainly seems to be
something that's that's one of actually
one of the consistently replicated
things in evolutionary psychology is
that men are much much more likely to
cheat than women
didn't you
say that infidelity is heritable
yes yes certainly so people that have
and that's another thing about
personality and behavior we typically a
lot of the time we think about
heritability as if it only applies to
physical features but Heritage you know
eye color and something like that
heritability applies to behavior in
behavioral genetics there's something
called the 50 050 rule which is kind of
the broad observation that about half of
personality is heritable and sometimes
when people say personality I think they
don't also understand that it also means
Behavior the way that personality is
expressed so people that have had
parents who have cheated they're more
likely to be victims of infidelity and
more likely to cheat the same with
something like divorce people who have
parents who have divorced more likely to
divorce and so there's a question about
heritability there like oh is this
because they learn those behaviors from
the environment or because uh they it's
something genetic and certainly the
outcome in either sense is the same you
know someone with that background if the
likelihood is higher if it's caused by
genetics or the environment
is perhaps immaterial as far as that
outcome
the degree of heritability is usually
estimated by twin studies right so twins
that are raised and you can see how much
that correlates based on a monozygotic
or desirotic twin so that's kind of how
these heritability estimates come about
but certainly many many behaviors yeah
and infidelity among those and divorced
as well what about uh
the consistency of somebody who's
cheated before to cheat again
ah okay so perhaps not as high as we
would think that it's not that a lot of
people have actually I say a lot I let's
let's say I read a paper originally I
actually made a video on this I think it
was about 30 of women that reported
having cheated in the past but a second
time and it was much much lower it was
something like 30 of those women so a
lot of people might cheat once and
actually never do it again certainly is
that there's that aphorism you know once
a cheater always a cheater and someone
who has cheated in the past probably
does have a higher likelihood of
cheating in the future but it's
certainly not something that guarantees
a history of infidelity if someone has
never cheated of course you know that
would be uh the lowest risk for future
infidelity what about the heritability
of facial attractiveness we spoke about
that earlier on and we're already on
heritability here
uh so I don't know about the
heritability of facial attractiveness
specifically certainly uh it would be
very high because it's a physical
feature and physical features are
typically things we think of as very
very heritable something like height for
example has a heritability of of 0.8 and
I imagine a lot of physical features are
like that the environmental effects on
your physical appearance uh I guess it
depends on an individual level what
you're exposed to if someone doesn't
ever take care of their face or
something like that you know certainly
that uh can lower facial attractiveness
over time but in a lot of sense uh your
face is kind of what you're born with
yeah it's interesting because the sexy
sun hypothesis which I learned from
Costello as well was a a very
interesting uh justification that one of
the reasons that a woman would find a
man attractive and this is this ties
into pre-selection which I I'm aware is
kind of also been decapitated with a
replication crisis but if other women
find a man attractive it's likely that
his genes will produce sons that future
women will also find attractive so the
whatever like um grandparent Optimizer
gene expression thing going on here
where you say okay well if I have sex
with that man and we have some Sons
together we'll have sexy sons and those
Sons will be able to reproduce more
effectively
yeah you know that's certainly something
that you would expect that traits that
are attractive over time will be
propagated more and they will continue
to appear more and you can get kind of a
runaway of those traits as well a very
good example of that would be something
like the peacock and the peacock tail
where originally the bird did not have
this giant giant tail but it was
something that facilitated that sexual
selection and over time grew and now you
have this this very beautiful bird huge
tail even if it's a detriment in other
ways so as far as if it's something that
people deliberately think about probably
not like I need to find someone
attractive so I'll have attractive kids
maybe it might be a consideration but
it's probably more like I like this
person I'm attracted to them in the
moment isn't there a
species of deer or something
That Grew antlers that were so big that
the entire species went extinct
that certainly could be uh the case I
think that might even be called
fisherian Runaway the idea that a trait
is attractive and selected for in to an
extent that eventually becomes
detrimental the pickup tail is kind of
like that it's large enough where you
could say okay this bird might not be
able to escape Predators as well so
there there's a trade-off there in some
sense when these traits become very very
attractive even height in human beings
is kind of like that taller people
suffer more risks as far as health is
concerned so you might ask like hey why
is height being selected for well it's
attractive subjectively for one but also
the detriment is perhaps not so high
that uh that it's like killing people
before they're able to reproduce yeah
the trade-off between these two things
I'm pretty sure it was a type of deer or
something that grew antlers that were so
large that it couldn't support its own
head and yet sexual selection was
preferencing these so much that
fisherian runaway had just
away it goes
um and it got to the stage all they were
so slow and so uh lumbering that there
were just eaten by predators and your
good kids came over which I thought is
pretty hilarious I remember reading the
first ever time that I learned about
fisherin runaway must have been before I
even started the podcast like six years
ago and I was reading this article about
Snapchat filters remember when the girls
used to use Snapchat filters and they
would make their eyes a little bigger
and they would put those little dots on
their cheeks and hilariously they would
also put a mask used to be a mask with
like a bee kind of like how we used in
covid
um which is also pretty funny that girls
were using that previously as a
I don't know it was like cute because
you only get to see the eyes I guess if
you've only done half of your Face's
makeup that day you can you can get away
with looking all right
um but also that as soon as covid comes
around I bet that that filter went
completely through the floor because
nobody wanted to be associated with
being the sort of person that would
choose to wear a mask especially not a
virtual one but yeah this for sharing
runaway thing you know the big eyes The
Rosy Cheeks blah blah uh suggested that
you could get to the stage where
um if guys had an unbounded desire for
female butts and boobs that you might
have you know these
um
scoliosis
like having to wear a back brace uh
women the only way that they could
support these massive breasts and this
ass is if they do uh that's what men
want and this runaway would occur as
well and one other thing
that we've spoken about privately and I
was fascinated with and I really want to
dig into is this decline in sexual
desire by relationship length in men
versus women so this is Men First and
women second and this is the decline in
sexual desire by relationship length so
under one year 13 men to 21.5 women one
to five years 15.3 men 28 and a half
percent women five to fifteen years
fourteen point nine percent men to 39.8
percent women so that's actually gone
down a little a little bit for men and
then 15 plus years 16.1 percent for men
to 40 for women so it seems like women
kind of top out within that 15-year age
range and that men have still got a
little bit more to go
why do you think that this is the case
we would have presumed you know from
first principles that a man's desire for
sexual variety would have led him to be
more
um uh libidinous and and look to stray
from his ever-aging wife uh why is it
the case that women's sexual desire
seems to decline more quickly and higher
during a relationship
well that's a very good question part of
this can probably just explain by
something like the libido Gap that there
tends to be a large difference in libido
in desire at the very very outset for
men and women but over time you know
that's something that can contribute
probably to divorce as well and to
relationship satisfaction this this big
decline in libido over time what could
be the case that I've heard hypothesized
as well is that
as time goes on if a woman has no
children or if she has a past child
there could be a benefit to finding a
new mate at that point right if the
child is old enough kind of to take care
of itself if you do not need kind of the
pair bond at that point then moving on
to a new relationship to have the
genetic material of another person to
increase genetic diversity could have
some benefit so there could kind of be
an evolutionary basis for that very very
gradual decline over the long term
that's one hypothesis I don't know how
much uh validity that has but it's
something that I've seen out there
certainly a another uh explanation that
I think is a bit more intuitive is that
when you look at decline over a very
long period of time like 15 years so
we're talking about people that are
married and the average age for marriage
is about 30. these are people that when
you see that peak of decline we're
looking at people who are about 45 years
old by the time people are 45 years old
uh certainly not only has a lot of the
novelty in a relationship worn off which
may or may not matter but a lot of
people aren't taking good care of
themselves at that point you know
obesity crisis people have gotten older
they're less physically attractive
libido for men and women both goes down
with time and some of that could just be
due to kind of that General aging
process as well over time
because certainly interesting it's
interesting to me that it's just so much
higher you know women double even from
year one where you already can uh factor
in that base rate of women's lower uh
the the libido Gap it doubles for women
and for many increases by like 20
percent
it goes down it does it goes down a lot
and certainly a single good explanation
I don't know if it exists something else
to consider as well is that women in
general have lower sexual satisfaction
as you mentioned uh as far as orgasms as
well certainly something like the orgasm
Gap and if you're already starting out
at kind of a low place
uh it can drop a lot to zero without a
problem if you're starting at a higher
place that might be enough motive to
kind of continue with sexual behavior
and to seek it out even if the sex isn't
that good and you're a man say you
started you know you report I have 90
sexual satisfaction and then it drops
down to 70 and it's like well whatever
the sex you know at least I still get
off for a woman it might be like I
didn't get off that much and now this
thing is just an ordeal and a chore and
it's not it's something not only that I
I don't get pleasure from but that is
actively disagreeable to me and so maybe
that can explain some of that that big
drop as well uh because discussed
sensitivity for women is significantly
higher and as soon as you drop through a
particular threshold from that sex goes
from I imagine yeah William Costello
said
um sex to men is like pizza there is
good pizza and there's Pizza there is
good sex and there is sex whereas to
women there is such a thing as bad sex
to men there isn't really not such a
thing as bad sex unless you descend into
some Ninth Circle of Hell after a night
out
um I wonder as well
uh
how much perhaps
the introduction of hormonal birth
control has got to do with this you know
the fact that women self-rated sexual
satisfaction when they come off birth
control tends to be lower than that of
women who met their partner when they
were off birth control and are now still
off birth control if you're naturally
cycling throughout your levels of sexual
satisfaction don't decline as much and
this is because women who are on birth
control seem to prioritize different
sorts of criteria amongst mates they
tend to
opt for more provisioning uh they seem
to have a greater preference for
objective metrics of success like income
and education and that means that when
they come out of a home on field stupid
they can actually be like oh my God I'm
in a relationship with a guy that I
don't find that's sexual sexually
satisfactory
um however you can see that this is the
case because the natural cycling uh data
that's been assessed has arousal level
at exactly the same so it's the same
level of arousal women that are on
hormonal birth control and women that
are off hormonal birth control the
problem that arises is the level of
sexual satisfaction has decreased quite
sharply for women who decide to come off
and that would be you know during this
period as well perhaps you've been
together for you know between two and
four years something like that no well
maybe we've got married and now we're
going to try for kids because you know
typically that's still the way a lot of
people decide to do it uh even though
it's actually less than uh 50 now so
50.1 percent of children born a 51.6 of
children born outside of wedlock in the
UK last year which is pretty crazy
that's huge yeah and certainly you know
as you said hormonal birth control there
there's actually a lot of mixed results
on that as far as the direction that it
pushes things and on an individual level
as well some people will report hormonal
birth control absolutely killed my
libido things were good when I was on it
until I stopped I took it and then it
raised my libido and the same thing it's
you know I think sometimes I think men
might not understand it intuitively as
much but imagine as a man if if you took
something that suppressed your
testosterone or they've increased your
testosterone or that could do either and
you weren't entirely sure uh certainly
that can affect your libido in huge ways
and it can have long-term lasting
effects and if you look at that over
something like a 15-year trajectory
where you also have other things going
on for example perhaps early menopause
as well or just natural shifts and
fertility over time those are all things
that can come together and cause huge
changes in libido that might last
forever and uh yes as well if it is on
average people getting married at age 30
you know menopause is going to kick in
at around about that 15 year mark But if
it's at around about the 15 year mark
then you've already seen the Lion's
Share of the doublet well you've seen
all of the increase right so that
wouldn't actually explain anything
strange very very interesting one of the
other things I've noticed you you've
been accused of having a pro-feminist or
a purple pilled view of dating why do
you think that is
yeah I see people say that occasionally
you know but I I also see it depends who
is disagrees with what I have written at
the time because someone might say oh
it's an incel and then someone might say
oh it's a feminist so if someone is
coming from a very different perspective
whatever I say is got to be something
that they don't like to hear in that
sense certainly I don't come from a
perspective that uh that hates women or
that hates men or or anything like that
and I try to report the research and
what it says and sometimes that doesn't
paint men in a very good light sometimes
it doesn't paint women in a very good
light and in cases where the research
might say oh you know here's something
kind of unflattering about men then oh
why don't you say something bad about
women and if it's the other case then
then perhaps I'm a misogynist or
something so certainly a lot of that is
from the perspective of individuals in
that sense yeah I understand completely
it's
um the conversation around men's and
women's discourse has become so adverse
aerial online and it's one of the things
that I've really loved about doing the
episodes over the last sort of 12 to 24
months on this show because
at least 50 of the evolutionary
psychology researchers have brought on
have been women
um you know and they're just as scathing
of women as anybody else in fact most of
the episodes that are critical of women
have come from women which has been
particularly useful for me because if it
was the other way around it would be far
easy to criticize what we were talking
about but
yeah man I I if I could gift the entire
world of dating advice one thing
it would probably be to learn about the
lack of Interest intersexual competition
that people have going on and learn
about how vicious intrasexual
competition is it's like look you're not
competing with the people across the
other side of the aisle from you you're
competing within your own tribe like men
compete with men for men stuff and women
compete with women for women's stuff
that's why there's gossip and that's why
there's posturing and that's why men
lower their voices when they're with
other men and around attractive women
like you know all of the Myriad ways
that were completely stupid like
that isn't because those people of a
different sex to us are the ones that
are fundamentally are adversary they're
our Ally you know they're collaborators
they're supposed to be someone that
complements our life that doesn't
compete with us within it and um
the problem is that it's not a
particularly sexy narrative to sell
online because I wrote this in the
newsletter actually that I put out today
which is
anybody online who generates Goodwill
toward themselves by primarily
identifying an out group that you're all
supposed to hate is someone that
immediately I'm super skeptical about
like my grift and and chill radar is on
at maximum hypersensitivity because look
like if you can't get people to bind
together over the mutual love of an
in-group or of whatever movement it is
even if the movement is simply curiosity
or knowledge or intellectual
um like trustworthiness
if you can't get people to bind together
over that a very easy charlatans
solution is going to be to say yeah but
at least we're not them they're the
problem you go okay I
apologies shrinivasam was on the show
and he said a few months ago
um socialism is the quickest route to be
able to put yourself at the head of a
mob because what you do is you identify
the people that have everything and we
don't and they're the problem and this
is it's like sour grapes at an
existential level that people within and
this is the same dude this isn't just
the the world of like bad men's advice
this is the world of bad women's advice
as well like um pink pill you know or
the female what was it female dating
strategy that stuff as well all of that
is exactly the same like you're pointing
at the other side and saying that
they're the problems go okay really
great High agency Sovereign way to take
control of your life there
yeah definitely as far as relationship
outcomes go if you go into a
relationship hating the opposite gender
or looking at the opposite gender uh
very negatively that's already
sabotaging your relationship from the
beginning how are you going to have a
relationship with someone who you view
negatively as some intrinsic part of
them you know that's a lot of the
discourse in these manuscript
communities online dating communities
not just manuscript but dating
communities as you mentioned for women
as well which is a lot of negativity and
vitriol toward the other sex and
certainly that's extremely
counterproductive if you want to have a
good relationship especially
something interesting in the data as
well is when people get older they lose
most of their friend group this occurs
about the 30 mid 30s and the person may
spend most of their time with is going
to be the person they're in a
relationship with friend groups go to
zero for most people at that point and
they spend most of the time with
colleagues at work or a spouse and it's
like okay you know if you're a
heterosexual man in a relationship
you're going to be spending the next 20
years with one woman you know do you
want to hate that person or do you want
to have like a good time with that
person something else actually very very
related to that so Dr John gottman who
is a marriage researcher classic classic
research of his he identified these four
horsemen of the uh divorce apocalypse so
to speak which he could observe couples
and some of this has been questioned if
it's replicable or not but the idea was
he could observe these couples and
predict who would be divorced within
like the next couple of years with like
90 accuracy and he identified these four
things and the top one of those was
contempt and that's what you see an
enormous amount of in these these
relations are in these discourses of
relationships which are primarily like
you mentioned like female dating
strategy or red pill or something these
are people that are struggling to date
and struggling to form relationships and
at the same time they hold massive
contempt for man or for women
respectively and it's like wow you're
already entering this with like the
behavior that just predicts right at the
very outset that your relationship is
going to fail
dude I love that look Alexander I really
appreciate your work everybody needs to
go and follow you on Twitter and check
out the stuff that you do where should
they go
well on Twitter at date psych I got a
website datesychology.com and uh YouTube
is alex.date site so any of those mostly
active on Twitter and uh yeah all right
man until next time thank you thank you
great great chat what's happening people
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe peace
[Music]